deutschland am dienstag schon dass sie
mit dabei sind in der nacht sind drei
flieger mit solarwafern zurück nach
deutschland gekommen und die biologen
professor protzer beantwortet gleich
ihre fragen hier bei uns die neuesten
entwicklungen rund um die korona krise
die gibt es jetzt in unserem corona
kompakt der flughafen köln bonn in der
nacht wer hier landet der hat es nach
hause geschafft in zeiten des corona
virus das auswärtige amt lässt deutsche
urlauber aus krisengebieten holen alle
passagiere werden vom zuständigen
gesundheitsamt empfangen und ärztlich
begutachtet
hier sind es in dieser nacht vier
menschen die mit dem verdacht auf eine
infektion ins krankenhaus gebracht
werden alle anderen müssen sich in
häuslicher quarantäne begeben
doch auch wer nicht auf weltreise ist
ist zu außergewöhnlichen maßnahmen
gezwungen soziale isolation und
mindestabstand jeder geht damit anders
um
also ich gehe immer rausgehen wahl ins
fitnesscenter ist kann ich mir aber ich
muss raus
für uns ist es sehr wichtig obwohl wir
an gott nach haben aber trotzdem wir
wollen ja auch bisher angehen
peter häberle was tut eigentlich kein
mulmiges gefühl weil wir beide denke ich
noch obwohl wir schon zur altersgruppe
gehören noch effizienter dem ernst der
lage also mit positiven denkens begegnen
das ist jetzt gefragt so wie auch
erfindergeist eine brauerei aus dem
bremen nutzt nun überschüssigen alkohol
zur produktion dringend benötigter
desinfektionsmittel
wir stellen am standort alkoholfreies
bier her und bei dieser alkohol bei der
herstellung ist es so dass alkohol
wasser gemischen anfällt und dieses
alkohol wasser gemischt kann den
weiteren verarbeitungsstufen so auf
konzentriert werden dass der die
konzentration ausreichend ist um als
desinfektionsmittel weiter verwendet zu
werden
50.000 liter davon im wert von
anderthalb millionen euro die partei
stellt das kostenlos zur verfügung vor
allem dem lebensmittelhandel und
krankenhäusern
wir sitzen ja alle in einem boot um die
ausbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen um
das alle möglichst zu tun unseren
mitmenschen und uns selber zu schützen
und das was wir als unternehmen dazu
beitragen können das tun wir die
ausbreitung des corona virus in
deutschland verlangsamen noch kann keine
entwarnung gegeben werden mit stand von
heute nachmittag gibt es laut johns
hopkins universität 31 1260
nachgewiesene infizierte 749 menschen
haben die infektion inzwischen
überstanden
die professorin ulrike protzer ist
biologin an der tu münchen und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet lange hieß es ältere
menschen seien gefährdet als jüngere
schwer an corona zu erkranken jetzt soll
es immer mehr schwere corona symptome
auch bei jüngeren menschen geben wie es
das zu erklären
die infektionsgefahr für einen jungen
und einen alten menschen ist
letztendlich die gleiche dass da gibt es
keinen großen unterschied da macht das
virus auch keine unterschiede
das risiko dann ertrag zu erkranken
das heißt eine lungenentzündung zu
entwickeln schwerer zu erkranken dass es
bei älteren menschen höhe
wenn sich also 100 ältere menschen
anstecken dann ist das risiko dass zehn
bis zwanzig eine lungenentzündung
entwickeln wenn sich 100 jüngere
anstecken dann ist das allerhöchstens
einer das heißt aber nicht dass kein
jüngerer mensch schwer erkranken kann
und kann man da im verlauf sagen dass
das jetzt tatsächlich sich verändert hat
da hin zu den jüngeren
nein absolut nicht sind natürlich die
älteren vorsichtiger gewesen da haben
sich weniger infiziert dh da werden dann
auch weniger relativ gesehen schwer
krank bei den jüngeren die waren am
anfang ein bisschen vorsichtig da haben
sich mehr infiziert danke frau professor
potter und gleich stehen sie uns ja noch
für weitere zuschauer fragen zur
verfügung
einige geschäfte lassen sich wohl schon
was einfallen um die hamsterkäufe zu
verhindern bei uns gab's in einem
supermarkt zum beispiel nur ein kilo
mehl an der kasse pro person
die stadt hanau ist jetzt ganz strikt da
gibt's ärger wenn man nicht in
handelsüblichen mengen einkauft
leere regale keine nudeln kein reis auch
das berühmte toilettenpapier fehlanzeige
bilder in zeiten der korona krise weil
viele mehr kaufen als sie brauchen
bleibt für andere nichts mehr übrig kann
ich nicht verstehen dass überhaupt
hamsterkäufe stattfinden
leere regale sind nur dem geschuldet
weil die ware ist da gut ich habe heute
morgen auch mein spülen nicht bekommen
was ich sonst kaufe ja mein gott und das
geschirr wird schon sauber werden es ist
definitiv so die übertreiben es mit den
einkäufen man sieht auch jährige regale
es ist schon fast gierig krank in meinen
augen jemand der so etwas macht ist
asoziale nachschub ist ja da
das muss eigentlich nicht sein mit der
hamsterkäufe 95 prozent der menschen
verhalten sich vernünftig auch in hanau
so schätzt der oberbürgermeister dort
doch bei den restlichen fünf prozent
hätten all die appelle der letzten
wochen nichts genutzt
deshalb greift die stadt hanau nun zu
einer drastischen maßnahme und verbietet
per anordnung die hamsterkäufe
ich will mit den anordnungen die
menschen schützen die für ihren einkauf
von nudeln reis hygieneartikel zu spät
dran sind weil andere ihnen vor der nase
alles in handelsüblichen mengen alles
weg gekauft haben
und das trifft übrigens in besonderer
weise die heldinnen und helden des
alltags aus den kliniken aus den
altenpflegeheimen die abends nach hause
kommen auf dem weg noch was einkaufen
wollen und vor leeren regalen stehen bei
der durchsetzung des verbots
unterstützen die städtischen
ordnungskräfte die sicherheitsleute der
einkaufsmärkte hanau wird so auch
diejenigen schützen die tag für tag mit
unvernünftigen käufern zu tun haben
die kassiererinnen und kassierer
[Musik]
begegnet ist jedenfalls teilweise mit
anpöbeln mit beleidigungen das finde ich
finde ich skandalös und deswegen müssen
wir auch die kassiererinnen und
kassierer in schutz nehmen
doch nicht jedem schmeckt das verbot
unnötig meint etwa der
einzelhandelsverband
also wir sind natürlich immer skeptisch
wenn es verbote gibt es wegen haben
unsere unternehmen vor allen dingen die
lebensmittelhändler in anderen weg
genommen haben mit einer
anzeigenkampagne die verbraucher
angesprochen haben gesagt es ist
genügend für alle da das zeigt sich ja
auch jeden tag doch in hanau scheint
sich die harte gangart gegen
hamsterkäufe schon am ersten tag zu
bewähren und einige kommunen haben
mittlerweile nachgezogen und ebenfalls
verbote von übermäßigen einkäufen
erlassen
wir merken sie jeden tag sie haben viele
fragen viele menschen sind stark
verunsichert wegen der korona krise und
genau diese unsicherheit und diese angst
nutzen kriminelle natürlich auskommen
fake angebote für schutzkleidung oder
mit vermeintlichen insider corona tipps
per mail von internetbetrügern dirk
kuchel bekommt jeden tag hunderte mails
mit angeboten rund um die korona krise
schutzkleidung masken angebliche
medikamente oder impfungen das netz ist
voll mit heilsversprechen die nichts
anderes sind als der versuch die nutzer
in die falle zu locken
der angebliche anbieter safe maß zum
beispiel wirbt mit dem richtigen schutz
vor ansteckung solche mails nicht öffnen
ich würde ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
reingucken weil es handelt sich in den
meisten fällen ja um spam und das heißt
also von um nachrichten die sie gar
nicht verlangt haben von shops die sie
vielleicht gar nicht kennen und dann
sollte man grundsätzlich vorsichtig sein
denn erstens ist ja ohnehin verboten
jemandem eine nachricht zu schicken
zu dem sie gar keine
geschäftsbeziehungen haben und behandelt
es in solchen fällen meistens wirklich
auch um fake shops und da wissen sie nie
ob irgendwas ankommen fake shops wie
medical smiles gmbh das unternehmen
wirbt auf seiner seite mit einem großen
angebot an gesichtsmasken und
zahlreichen anderen medizinischen
sicherheitsprodukten
zahlung per vorkasse geliefert wird nie
im impressum ist der unternehmenssitz in
halstenbek bei hamburg angegeben
besonders dreist an dieser adresse gibt
es eine zahnklinik die deswegen schon
häufig anrufe bekam ich glaube einfach
dass viele auf diesen zug der angst
aufspringen die fake sozusagen noch mal
neu zum leben erweckt werden also dass
in dem bereich gerade viel angst
herrscht und das heißt die leute wollen
sich schützen wollen auch sachen kaufen
und die gibt es dann vielleicht gibt es
keine einmalhandschuhe mir bei in der
drogerie markt und dann kauft man geld
im internet und überweist schnell kauft
sie zu überhöhten preisen und kaufte sie
vielleicht auch bei shops die gar nicht
existieren ich glaube da wird mit der
angst geschäfte gemacht und dadurch
werden wahrscheinlich auch mehr fake
angebote wieder entstehen
desinfektionsmittel gesichtsmasken
handschuhe die internet betrüger suchen
nach produkten die derzeit nicht überall
zu finden sind wir auf die elektronische
post reagiert oder auf die links darin
klickt landet auf internetseiten mit
schadsoftware
auch in dem fall sind die betrüger
erfinderisch die johns hopkins
universität etwa hält eine aktuelle
pandemie karte bereit betrüger fälschen
das aussehen ihrer seite und haben beim
ersten klick leichtes spiel wenn ich's
anklicke würde ich bei einem schlecht
gesicherten system ein trojaner auf
meinem computer installieren und das
würde dann den kriminellen ermöglichen
beispielsweise bankdaten auszuspähen
kreditkarteninformationen aber auch alle
daten die auf dem rechner sich befinden
das kann so weit gehen dass
tastatureingaben mitgeschnitten werden
die hacker also passwörter lesen können
deutschlands sicherheitsfirmen haben
darauf reagiert sie bieten schutz
software derzeit kostenlos an sicherheit
zum nulltarif zumindest für das kommende
halbe jahr
viele haben jetzt auch angst um ihren
job müssen an die reserven vielleicht
sogar an die altersvorsorge besonders
hart trifft es auch die schausteller und
marktbetreiber die ihr nun mal von
menschenmassen leben in hamburg ist der
fischmarkt leer und auch das größte
volksfest im norden der hamburger dom
ist abgesagt worden
das heiligengeistfeld mitten in hamburg
müsste jetzt eigentlich voll sein voll
mit schaustellerwagen fahrgeschäften
zockerbuden und gastronomie müsste die
absage wegen corona kam als die ersten
bereits aufbauten die erste sichere
einnahmequelle für die schausteller im
norden einfach weg ich sag mal wenn zum
sommerdom nicht irgendwie wieder mal der
bald ins laufen kommt dann muss ich
glaube ich mal die an die altersvorsorge
rangehen und dann sind halt ihre
reserven die man eigentlich für später
in ferner zukunft zurückgelegt hat die
sind dann aber auch dann irgendwann alle
vermutlich so die schätzung des
verbandes werden es 30 prozent der
betriebe nicht schaffen
ich sehe das eher realistisch und ich
weiß ganz bestimmt dass einige wirklich
kurz vor der insolvenz stehen wenn da
nicht irgendeine art von hilfe kommt
erstmal in den nächsten sechs wochen
oder so was weil es geht dann wird dann
halt auch düster absagen gab es nur
wegen hochwassers doch jetzt hat das
corona virus auch hamburgs
touristenmagneten in die knie gezwungen
diesen hafenklang gibt es bis auf
unbestimmte zeit nicht mehr
nach außen typisch hanseatisch im
geldbeutel aber macht der fischmarkt die
hälfte der wochen einnahmen aus dass
halten die großen betriebe länger durch
als die kleinen die auswirkungen aber
sind spürbar
personal wird schon entweder ganz ganz
toll ist auf kurzarbeit geschickt oder
aber sofort betriebsbedingt gekündigt
das heißt da sind dann jetzt auch schon
wieder ein paar familien die gar nicht
wissen wie sie den nächsten monat über
stehen sollen weil die wieder auf dem
dom ihr geld verdient hätten die
wochenmärkte sind noch geöffnet die
plätze aber fest vergeben für die
schausteller die hier nicht vertreten
sind gibt es keine zusätzlichen flächen
zumal die kunden durch die
einschränkungen im öffentlichen bereich
immer weniger werden
[Musik]
was auch immer ich glaube dass das hier
noch bleibt wenn es nicht da würde
müsste man das irgendwie auch alles
würden mindestens drei millionen weniger
besucher potenzielle hotelgäste
einkäufer und dombesucher die stadt und
bund das ausgleichen wollen noch gibt es
keine pläne wie so viele branchen sind
auch die schausteller durch das corona
virus stark getroffen egal welche
ausgleichsmaßnahmen es geben wird der
dom der hafengeburtstag und der
fischmarkt werden wohl so schnell nicht
wieder klingen
ähnlich wie den schaustellern geht es
der frisörin melanie rose auch sie
musste ihren salon wegen der korona
krise schließen
aber sie hat wahrscheinlich mehr glück
als viele andere betroffene ihr
vermieter hat ihr nämlich kurzerhand die
miete erlassen
friseurmeisterin melanie rose steht vor
einer finanziellen herausforderungen
wegen der verordneten schließung ihres
geschäftes brechen sämtliche einnahmen
weg aber die fixkosten bleiben
man hat auf jeden fall angst was die
zukunft angeht weil man nicht weiß kann
ich den laden halten oder kann ich ihn
nicht halten was passiert mit meiner
angestellten da sind das ist schon mit
großen ängsten verbunden
die kosten für die miete entfallen erst
einmal denn die wurde ihr kurzerhand
erlassen von hausbesitzer gesagt neuhaus
erst per whatsapp dann ganz offiziell
dürfen wir leider nicht solidarität in
zeiten der krise ersten moment ich war
ja sprachlos
das hat mich in dem moment getroffen wie
ein schlag also es war emotionen kochten
über mir liefen die tränen und ich war
einfach dankbar und überglücklich wir
wissen jetzt nicht wie lange das dauert
deswegen natürlich erst mal ein monat
wenn es dann zwei monate dauert dann
natürlich auch zwei monate weil ich will
auf jeden fall dass die haarsalon der
friseursalon am ende erhalten bleibt und
deswegen würde ich auch jeden weg
mitgehen
um sich zu bedanken postet melanie wie
hilfe ihres vermieters auf facebook mit
erfolg der post bekommt mehr als 30.000
likes und wird fast 140.000 mal geteilt
vielleicht regt diese aktion ja andere
an ebenfalls solidarität zu zeigen
ja das wäre doch schön frau professor
ulrike protzer ist biologin an der tu
münchen und beantwortet jetzt einige
zuschauer fragen zum beispiel schreibt
marion r welche vor erkrankungen vor
allem bei älteren menschen stellen ein
erhöhtes infektionsrisiko dar
das infektionsrisiko ist eigentlich
immer das gleiche egal ob mann
vorerkrankungen hat oder nicht der
unterschied ist macht diese infektionen
ein schwerer krank schwerer krank werden
vor allem diejenigen die vorerkrankungen
haben an der lunge herz kreislauf aber
auch erhöhter blutdruck und sogar
diabetes scheint ein risiko zu sein und
das rauchen im bett erfragt wir gehen
schon fast 40 jahre regelmäßig zur
grippeschutzimpfung haben wir da auch
einen schutz gegen korona leider nein
das hilft wirklich spezifisch gegen das
grippevirus nicht gegen des corona virus
aber zumindest hilft es einem mit beidem
konfrontiert zu werden
dann haben wir von jemandem eine anfrage
bekommen wie oft kann man eine
schutzmaske tragen bis sie ihre wirkung
verliert also schutzmasken verlieren vor
allem dann die wirkung wenn sie feucht
werden
das heißt in dem moment in dem sie
langsam feucht werden sollte ich sie zur
seite legen sollte ich sie trocknen
lassen dann kann man sie auch wieder
verwenden wenn es welche aus stoff sind
kann man sie auch waschen zwischendrin
und dann fragt noch jemand bin ich schon
ansteckend wenn ich infiziert wurde oder
erst wenn sich symptome zeigen man ist
schon ansteckend so etwa eventuell 24
maximal 48 stunden bevor die symptome
auftreten
aber nach der ansteckung der dauert
schon ein paar tage bis man dann
infektiös wird b fritze fragt warum kann
man die tests nicht zu hause machen und
dann vielleicht einfach per post
verschicken
es ist schon sehr wichtig dass das
testmaterial was man gewinnt auch
wirklich korrekt gewonnen ist an der
richtigen stelle
und auch ausreichend denn ansonsten sind
die tests nachher einfach nicht nicht
valide nicht aussagekräftig und wenn ich
die zu mit der post verschickt ist
natürlich auch ein hohes risiko für
denjenigen der die post transportiert
deswegen ist es nicht erlaubt
frau k schreibt ich arbeite in einer
klinik darf ich meine tätigkeit noch
ausführen wenn uns keine
desinfektionsmittel und keine geeigneten
schutzmasken mehr zur verfügung stehen
also ich hoffe nicht dass wir in diese
situation kommen ich weiß dass
schutzkleidung und auch der infektions
mittel sind aber ich glaube da können
wir uns schon auch auf unseren staat
verlassen dass der uns hilft das der
schutzkleidung besorgt es gibt ja
schutzkleidung zum beispiel in china die
jetzt einfach große vorräte wieder haben
da würde ich mich mal drauf verlassen
dass dieses wort das hoffentlich für uns
geregelt wird
die hoffen wir das beste danke professor
ulrike protzer unser corona kompakt
finden sie täglich auch im internet auf
youtube und zwar auf dem kanal der zdf
heute außerdem können sie uns weiter
ihre fragen an unsere experten schicken
von denen wir dann einige hier im studio
beantworten werden die e mail adresse
dafür ist corona kompakt zdf.de